what up guys back at the barbell brigade
office and it's a freaking moose
look at that what in the heezy faux
sheezy
is going on
no i'm just kidding we got a mess on
purpose because we got a big photo shoot
today
so if you guys been following me and the
barbell page and jill's page you saw
that we just dropped the lifestyle
collection one which are our flannel
jackets super sick it's a polyester wool
blend so it stays really warm
pretty much wrinkle free look at that
and then it has a satin lining so it's a
true jacket goes on really easy and it
has a nice
fleece hood got that drop shoulder cut
so it accentuates the shoulders gives
you that extra room for movement we
dropped those with our stretch denim
jeans
that you guys have seen me rock
where it's made specifically with people
for people with thicker thighs
butt and hips
so that um like because i call myself
like a tweener right like i usually like
wearing jeans where if my my dream jean
would be 34 inch waist with the butt of
the gene of a 36 inch waist jean and
then back down to a 34 inch
waisted pants and that's exactly what we
did we added extra room around the hips
and the butt
and then uh we tapered it back down to a
nice like skinny ankle while keeping it
two-way stretch so it moves with you and
it's super lightweight
so you guys saw that
but what we haven't shot yet is the
lifestyle collection
two and that's our
stretch cargo just trying to make casual
clothes
real comfy
you know like you don't even have to be
a lifter but if you just like extra room
in those areas this is for you and it's
stretch and it's comfy made to travel
that's why you don't even need a belt
you just because you know when you go
through tsa your worst nightmare is take
your belt off sir and you're like oh i
gotta take it off so we made it elastic
we put a secret pocket right here so you
could put like pens
or whatever else you could put over here
and then we also have another stealth
pocket in the back so people try to
pickpocket you like hammer steal your
wallet but guess what
we got that covert pocket back there
extra utility pocket over here
and we're shooting these guys with our
stretch denim jackets you know what i'm
saying
same material two-way stretch nice and
thin so we're gonna be modeling these
today and jill's gonna be uh jill is
gonna shoot outside so i can't wait to
show you
her stuff because from all the modeling
pic pictures i've taken i think it shows
that it's more like guy centric
but i think some of the pieces it looks
really good on chicks too so check it
out
action hey what's up
welcome welcome to what it's my photo
shoot this is my debut of finally living
my dreams of being a model i've always
wanted to be a model really no no
but the flannel jacket looks good on you
what size is that so this is a large
i'm like really into baggy fits like as
you can see like i got this i don't even
know what size this shirt is it's like
so huge it looks double xl almost i
think it's like triple xl triple xl yeah
but this is a double look at that
branding don't watch put it back around
and then look at this material see i
really love this material could you go
like this
are you ready to see what's gonna happen
yeah watch
what what what the easy what the easy
[Music]
you ready to model or what damn justin's
ready
the dame's ready i was like where's our
time
what you're wasting our time am i yeah
what time did you say you just said it
was like one o'clock it is where the
film all right come on let's go let's go
start modeling come on hurry up come on
hurry hurry hurry here let's go woman
what's her name
what's her name
woman i appreciate that
i appreciate that what's your name again
you'll never assume
i appreciate it yeah do that do that
thing can you listen to justin
i keep wasting his time i'm so sorry
justin
damn
it's em walk look at that
all right so now my bear got the black
one on
with my leather chucks oh yeah that's a
nice steezy look right there yep so when
you go big and baggy yeah for females
specifically you can't i mean you can do
all big and baggy but you want some sort
of balance i like to counter balance the
baggie with something really short so
hold on orange something short yeah and
everything else is back it's cool or if
like most of it's bagging then i try to
wear tight pants can you zip it up
counterbalance a little bit zip it up so
people know what it looks like zipped
i wasn't up talking
well i told you to stop oh i didn't hear
it that looks good you turn around
see
look at that
it's that timeless black and gray goes
with everything got that raglan cut like
i was telling you guys about the satin
is what i really like because it goes on
easy huh it goes on super easy and it
feels really cool um this part can be a
little scratchy on the outside like this
just this material i mean yeah i mean
it's because it's wool right um but
because it's set on the inside you never
have to interact with it which i love
while geo is out there shooting now it's
my turn to come back and get dressed
and i got my black cargos
my tan one and my olive and also the two
denim jackets
i wear large i'm five nine one ninety
ish so i wear a large for all of them
they're all true to size meaning
most i think um
five nine 190 dudes are kind of tweeners
right like they're in between a large
and extra large with our brand since
we're trying to make clothes for people
with extra shoulders extra butt extra
hips it's perfect if you get a large
it's not going to feel too tight it's
going to be exactly what you need so if
that's what you're interested in make
sure you hit the link below to go
straight to bartlebrigade.com
and uh got these guys
bringing back the statement tees to go
along with
and then i just got some clean shoes i
look fresh in the chute and you guys
will see me model next
so i'm butt naked right now
it's because i'm in the middle of
changing out butt button i got underwear
on but um one thing that i saw was like
oh man this is really cool cause i'm so
in the apparel business i forget like
the steps that it takes to go from a to
z check it out this is how it started
it started off with just creating
the silhouettes and the cuts and then
the branding goes on and everything and
all my notes
that's crazy huh like and that's not
even me being at the manufacturer trying
on the fabrics and then going at two
inches here take one inch away from
there uh use this fabric because it
stretches better because it's light it
feels comfortable that doesn't even um
take into account all the r d that it
takes to go into all these things but
it's cool to go from here but bam
all the way to
bubba bam
wow
wow whoa whoa whoa
all right what you what you got on so i
got the new denim jacket it's two-way
stretch look at that see all that
shoulder room try doing this with your
denim jacket at home you're not gonna be
able to so i got this on i got the
stretched cargo's on
and just trying to make sure it fits
good
how do i look do i look good looks good
yeah you look dope you look comfy and
ready for all the conditions i could
bend my elbows
wow can you imagine this look how big
these biceps are why are you gonna rip
them
no not with these these are like these
are two-way stretch look at that oh okay
see that i love it
should i roll it up my sleeves
no just leave it down like this
i'm ready to go you feel like you're
going on a date
okay so i just did a wardrobe change put
the hair down
put some
oh hi
wow
wow okay we need to get in my shot dude
i'm making it better all right
there you go
okay he's getting out of here okay so
just changed into
i don't know wardrobe number three i
think and this is gonna be for our
lifestyle collection two
these are our cargo pants i absolutely
love the fitment it has like a not dad
take on some easily these could easily
turn into dead vents but i love these
they have um elastic band pockets
there's a hidden pocket up here
see that so you can put like
any extra stuff you want to put in here
there's another pocket
pocket pocket i love this zipper detail
here
because now
you just want them to float over the
pants
you want them to look cute
so i'm gonna keep the top very simple
straight forward white
keep it clean
this material is my favorite it is
so light so airy and it's perfect for
the upcoming spring right now we're in
lane it's a little bit warmer here than
it is in nevada so i appreciate this
material right now a ton of [ __ ]
hi hello
this is my second outfit i got the olive
green card goes on
uh this time i wore them untucked and
there's a zipper here so if you have
like a low profile shoe you could
actually open it up a little bit so that
it sits over the shoe nicely so it rests
instead of like crumples up so it
depends on how you like it sometimes
when i'm wearing high tops i like to
cuff them a little bit so it looks like
or i like it
so right now it's more of a look and i
got the black denim jacket on
no you don't have it i don't have it on
i'm about to put it on
and same thing got that stretch denim
bang
boom boom then you look good
see that's how justin makes me model
because
literally what do you have to say about
that justin
he's like
if anyone wants to book me you could
book me
like him shout out to justin i don't
know [ __ ] about modeling and he makes me
look happy no we can tell we can tell
you in photoshop
i know on my arms like this
he just took your head off and put it on
someone i put it on larry's body
i wish was on there his body's looking
6'3
me too let's see
but yeah like that it's good it's good
right that's good
um okay
my last outfit you look nice
got the black on black on black on black
and black with just a little bit of
white that goes
so this is still my favorite way to wear
it just tucked in a little bit
it's cool like that to me
but as you guys can see the last way you
can wear is with the zipper
um it's my last outfit and then we'll go
get something to eat after yaya
you're a [ __ ] cartoon character aya
wow captain morgan pose look at that oh
dang those are big quads there's a 600
squat leg right there no more
we just finished shooting and we're
wondering what we should eat
for dinner so i was on yelp
and then i typed in sushi and it just so
happened that my favorite sushi spot is
about to open right now but what's crazy
is we're still a good 15 minutes from
opening and look at the line
so there's a line that's forming from
there
all the way over here
and that's my favorite place by the way
sushi again it is
my favorite it's so
good so i hope we i think we will i
think for sure we will but we got justin
the team
and ma bear how long do you think it's
going to be before we get to the front
of the line well i mean
like the open first one to four but i
think
i think we'll fit
okay
i don't know i have no knowledge of it
it's just a straight i'm glad we came
here right away though because this
place is
pathetic
hey baby you'll see something crazy yeah
look at that
it's crazy huh that looks
dangerous oh [ __ ] they got it
oh what
let's do this oh that makes sense
that makes totally permanent fixture
that makes total sense yeah kinda keep
it as nice as possible
that's cool that's better than what you
did at your studio
hey dude don't make fun of me i did it
myself okay are you like gonna just
talking [ __ ] rampant like he's just been
hating on us all the time
but he's not our friend like i thought
you were you're just talking about who
the hell are your friends can't be nice
to everyone 100 yeah you're not going to
flip it on me dude i just flipped it on
you yeah that's so rude no you're the
ass put your mask on read in the
comments below
so one of my favorite things about
eating at this restaurant is sitting at
the bar because i've learned so many
cool like secret like sushi things you
can get like i would see someone order
like a hand roll with like the chopped
radish in it i'm like oh what's that and
people talk to each other or they'll get
like oyster thing mixed with whatever
and you get to learn about a lot of
different dishes that are custom at the
counter and you get to see a really cool
knife
so the first round i always like a
really nice
yellow tail because it's very very
refreshing and it opens up her palette
you guys ready
i'm super excited oh yeah supposed to
tuck this in
classless
just kidding
oh yeah thank you yellow tail
honest i want to see your reaction
hopefully we brought you guys
all right so this is called mozuku it's
like shredded mountain yam seaweed i
want you guys to try it if you like it i
like it
yeah it's slimy
it's really slimy but it's bomb though
that looks
nice
the texture right
usually only like super authentic places
have stuff like this which is why i'm so
excited
oh that's how you do it
that's good
yes
so good
um
the team's over there busting the asian
thing
taking pictures
that was bomb huh
okay
okay
also one of my favorite things here
because they do it so fancy like there's
ginger green onions all this stuff on it
look at that it's a work of art
that's cool
is
all right so justin is about to try
shrimp head fried well the frozen some
beer first time you put lebanon already
put the lemon on it
the
taking pictures okay makes me happy
the whole day i just bought it
did you do it again
good thing you have another one i know
it feels dangerous though it looks very
dangerous
sam's vlog mama bears ideas
okay
really good
very good damn flap flap going all in
today huh
make it worth the line weight i'll give
you this one
a little bit
a little bit of depth
look at that
ready yeah
you're gonna do for me
shut up
do it for me
it's good yeah
okay so that is my favorite [ __ ]
right there
that's uh
they wrap it in a uh
thank you
oh yeah
back at my mom's house
and this is literally what we
brought
okay not what we mean
me it's what i brought for the shoot it
has like shoes change of wardrobe i have
makeup more wardrobe a bunch of stuff
here i just like bringing a lot of
options and papa's being the cuniest
and uh you want to hear something cuny i
would ride my bike here and you know
those little those little dolly thingies
that like uh construction workers use
it's like it's like a it's like a
rectangle yeah it has like wood wood and
then four
four wheels and then you put something
heavy on top i would sit in it pretend
it was a car and i'd be like
i would go down this thing as a little
ass kid maybe even as old as taika oh
that's good yeah i would play here so
taiga gets to play in the same places i
would play
and the dogs oh this is shadow hi shadow
hey i think he's like part wolf part
husky
this is robert
and he's just a dirty old lad but
they're such good dogs they always say
hi to me every morning this dog is
really attached to my mom
and he's always always always waiting on
her
so cutie someone was playing with rocks
i think right now they're all at uh my
brother's house oh they're playing with
chalk look at them
how cute
so we're gonna go inside play with the
kiddos
finally spend some family time together
and i'll see you guys tomorrow bye